ていて料
皆さんこんにちはね紹介です a
私はですねドニス東京 c にあります東大の脳症で醸造用ブドウ
1用のですね原料ブドウの栽培技術に関する研究をやっています
ただまぁ私のですね能楽のキャリアのスタートは実は最初から不動ではなくてですね
おいその中でトマトですとかメロンと顔ですねどうやったら美味しく効率的に栽培
できるかという研究をやっていました
自分で実際に栽培をしながら研究をやってたんですが
まあよし前から隔離された狭い部屋の中でですねまぁ色々制御しながら栽培することに
だんだんだんだんは不自然さを感じてですね自分の中でちょっと続けられなくなったん
ですね
そこでドクターコースに進学するときに分野を大きく変えました
も森林生態の部屋に住んだんですが新潟のですね
まーす騎乗で有名な苗場山の曲げレンジとゲレンデの間に部なって雪が優先して生えて
いるんですけれどもこのブナ林で無駄の整備生態を研究することをやっていました
我々その上空の研究するときにですね樹木のすぐ近くターゲットとする樹木のすぐ近く
にこういう鉄塔でタワーを建ててですね
樹間にアクセスをしてその上でいろいろなその整理情報を取得するというようなことを
やってたんですけれども
だいたいこのターンの高さがですねまあ大最低でも20メートル高いと30m ぐらい
です
それぐらいところまでタワーの中にはしごをかけてですねポンポンポンポン吉登って
いって
ちょっと射しばだけだしてそこでショートしてました
こういったの林内でですね
樹木のその葉っぱがうっそうと茂っている10巻を下から見上げるとまぁこんな感じに
見えるんですけれども
横から見たらこの山は樹齢600年くらいのですね大木もあるような非常にあのう
う進んだ喰らいまくるクライマックスが林になってまして
まあこういう美しい景色の中でですねのんまんのびのびとというか自然を見つめながら
研究しました
まあないばだけじゃなくていろんなところで研究してたんですがこれはの静岡のですね
天龍にありますかんろん山というですね非常にありがたい名前の山の山頂付近でして
ここは神降臨
スギヒノキの人工林なんですが
人工人なんで間髪をします間伐をするとですねスポーンとこ開くところがあるんですね
これでいきますと
こういうところですね
スポーン耐えていますがそこの中がこんな感じになっています
ギャップっていうよく見ますけれども
木を切りますと光がパッと入っていきますのでそうすると動物のフンとかでですね
持ち込まれた植物がですね
マット仁芽吹いて
ここの林の中ではヤブムラサキとかですねクマイチゴとかいろんなその植物が
一気に万歳三唱したように夏場ですね一気に顎瀬に成長するんですね
あのうとにかくこの空いた空間をいち早く
占拠したいわけですね
主観競争っていうのがここで生じます
そういったのーた植物同士のですね羞恥間の争いを見ながら
似たような事って人間社会でもあるよねーなんていうことを感じながら仕事をしました
ジョークの上からですねその林を見ているともうこれ時間投影図とかあの
城北一途というんですけれども
どこのどこになんの木が生えていてどういう時間を計上しているかというのを書いた絵
なんですね
こういうオムニブナのお囃子を買いたいなんですけれども
どれ一つとして同じ形状の主観ってないわけですよね
同じところに同じ樹種ほぼ同じ tna 思った
木が生えていてもこんなに個性的なんですなんてでしょうねっていうのが私のテーマ
でした
それを植物のを特に水分整理にフォーカスをして研究してたんですが
植物というのは先も子供お話ししたいんですね氏間での競争もあれば
朱内での個体間の競争もあります
さらに言うとですね樹冠の中でこういう同じ3期につながっていても
梢館で光資源の獲得競争というのがあってですね
光をいっぱい稼げた方は生き残っていきますし稼ぎが悪かった方は長期的には枯れて楽
し
落ちていくんですね
こういう気は答えないでも厳しい生存競争があります
自然の中って本当に厳しいんですね常に戦いが張り付いています
こういったその自然の厳しさというのを見ながらまたそれをその摂陵ひもときながら
研究をやってたんですが本当にですね
先ほどちょっと話しましたが命の危険にまあまあいろいろさらされまして
タワーの上から起こる機落っこちる危険性もありますしその最たるものはオジアの
大地震て新潟で大地震あった時にちょうど私
余震が来た時にターンを終え乗ってました
ターンの上5m ぐらい入れます
がっしゃんがしちゃいましたああもうこれ落ちるかなーと思ったんですがなんとか生き
登りましてねぇ
そういうこともあったりですねターの上危ないからって言ってまぁご飯食べた後に
タワーの下で昼寝をしてたらですね今度なんかもに護送するんですね
こと黒い館で支え容保がごそっと出てくるんでしょ
ワーコレはもうまた主務かなと思いましたけれども
なんとかい気がおりましてもういい加減ちょっと山を利用等
矢野正言葉通り市に足着いたところでしょうと化した部屋と思ったので
ていうのをと更にもう一つえー文字ツアー
春眠整体の部屋に移る段階で将来的に私は醸造用ブドウの研究が痛いと思ってたので
ねぇ
まあいい頃合いかなということですねそこから文をさらにまた帰ることになりました
なぜ私がそのブドウの原料であるワインの原料であるブドウを研究したいと思いなった
かというとですね実はの運命的な出会いがあったんですね
この左側のワイン目寒めサピックスのプリミティーヴォディマンドゥーリアという安易
なんですがイタリアのシチリアで作られていればいいんです
このプリミティーヴォというのはイタリアを代表するブドウの品種なんですけれども
あの迷っただけじゃねーのって言われるかもしれませんがこのワインがですね濃霧と
非常にあのポップですごくハッピーになれたんですね
農産物でこんなに人を猫幸せにできるんだって言うんでも感動したんですよ
で
自分もこういうふうに作りたいと思ったんですよ
それが最初のきっかけですねえっ
このプリミティーヴォっていう編集はですね
その昔海を渡ってアメリカに持ち込まれてジンファンデルという名前をに変わりました
十神遺伝的にはほぼ一緒と言われています
え
このジンファンデルもちょっと味のスタイルが違うんですけれどもこの2つ非常に魅力
的なワインでこの2つとなんとか日本で作れないかというふうに思って誰もやってない
ので
これ将来に一つ自分の招待したいなと思ったんです
ねそういうは思いをですねええ
ちょうど2003年4年ぐらいだったんですがブログに綴ってたんですよ
当時まだあの堀江なんとかさんが警察の公約になれる前でライブドアブログがですね
非常に隆盛を誇ったころです
私はの樹木の水分線の献血傘寿水庵という名前のブログをやっていてここで自分がやっ
ていること
将来やりたいことっていうのをずっとですねあの情報支援したんですねそこに
山梨のぶどう農家がですね
の2人がですねこんなちょっといかついおっさんたちがですね
1なんか面白そうじゃんみたいなも確保してくるんですね
そこでまあいろいろこうやりとりがあって誓いながらとにかくいいか遊びに来いって
言われてショック以降私も行ったんですよ
で行くたんびに日中一緒に畑で仕事してその後温泉入ってひとっ風呂浴びて
a その後飯食いながら
まあカレーランチでまぁワイン飲みながらですね翌朝までひたすら
ブドウの職安を生理生態について質問を受けてそれ故答える見たずーっと繰り返しまし
た
それをやってたらまあ自分たちはやっぱりワインづくりが将来やりたいんだからなんか
でもその前の段階でやれることないかね楽しをして
で日本のそのやっぱりワイン作りにのクオリティを上げていくためには原料部の変質を
もっともっと上げていかないといけない
じゃあその研究やるよということでチームキスミントいう醸造用ブドウの栽培研究
グループ作りました
それがちょうど2004年の終わりぐらいです
でそうこうしてたらですねどんどん仲間が増えていきまして2010年にはようやく
念願のですねワイナリーを持つことができました
これはもうみんながですね人に何やりたいというのが明確に思ってその情報発信をして
たんで
まあ集まってきやすくとなったまあそういう環境ができてたんですね
でへまあ今でもみんなでまぁ
ツールでいるという状況です
まあただ言っても抑え最初からあの
順風満帆だったわけではなくてですねやっぱり畑の開墾というのは非常に大変でした
自分たちでですねショベルカーを借りてきてもともと桃畑だったところを開墾してです
ね
で棚を作ってようやく今声援になっています
でその中でですねまぁじゃあ何を栽培するんですかという話になった時にもちろん
メジャー品種は上ないと経済的に成り立たないんですけれどもやっぱり僕たちのチーム
のグループの
起こせよ
出さないといけないのでなんやるって言った時にやっぱジンファンデルでしょうって話
になって
primitive はちょっとないが手に入らなかったんですね今でも超日本には
入ってきてないんですが
チーファンレビューだったらなんとかなるかこれやろうということで作っちゃいました
日本の唯一我々のチームが我々のワイナリーが純ファンネルを今
製品
にかして世の中に出していますジンファンデルというのはロゼスタイルにするとマジ
ホワイトジンファンデルって言い方をするんですがホワイトジンファンデルというのを
今3年目の仕込みに入っているところですね
で馬う仲間のですね農家とか
醸造家の協力があって私はまあいまではそのブドウの栽培からそれから醸造のところ
まで
一貫して高携われるような環境を整えることができました
これをですねまぁ山梨で中心に当てた山梨中心に行ってたんですがまぁもったいないの
でできれば東大の中でもやりたいないということで2年前に
東大の洋上の中にですねヴィンヤードはとりあえず作りました今年何とかですね頑張っ
て試験醸造免許は取ろうかなというふうなところまできています
そういうスターのまあワイン作りに探査得る
携わる中でですね非常にあの私が問題意識を持つようなワードが出てきましてそれがの
コストパフォーマンスという言葉なんですが
ワインファンの人たちですがコストパフォーマンスという言葉を使うんですねコスト
パフォーマンスて様は書いてはですね少し
でも安くて良いものを買いたいという発想ですよね
ところが何故こういう感覚が上江芽生えたかというとまあ高等経済成長の中でですね
生産者と消費者の距離が極めて離れてしまう
それはなぜかというと流通 c 性も発達好きな方ですこれによって全然回転はですね
作り手の顔が見えなくなってしまったんですね
でももし作り手が親しい人
たらどうでしょう多少高くても多分皆さん支え買おうと思うと思います
スーパーなんかでですね
皆さんどうでしょうかねまあフルーツとか野菜を買われるときに値段表があったら当然
ちょっとでも安い方を選ぼうとしますよね
でもそれってどういう意味があるんでしょ
それによって何が起きているんでしょう考えられたことあるでしょうか
スーパーで皆さんがちょっとでも安いものを選ぶことによってないが起きているかと
いうと当然経済リスクをで性能化さに一方的に押し付けていることにつながるんですね
結果的にですね
非常にあのまあ抽象的な話に聞こえるかもしれませんが実際にそういう事がまあ細かく
分析していくと起きていまして
まぁこのままではいけないよねということでその
農業ってそもそもそもそもどういうものなんだろうとやっぱり生産者がいて消費者がい
て
途中にそれをまあ頒布してくれる人たちがいたり
はのこういう料理にするとおいしいよというのを示せる人たちがいたりいろんな人たち
が炭酸って食
ノート
いうものが正
維持発展されしていくわけですよ消費者というのは
買い支えることによって消費者が支え支えることによって食の多様性とかですね
文化としての食や農というものが
さらに良いものに発展していくわけで幸せの好循環を生むためにはやはり消費者が
買い支えていく必要があります
こういったことを感じながらですね農家とそれそれからま
レストランの料理の人たちとまたは院
ショップの人たちですね一緒にチームキス便というものを今はだ続けています
ね
私はその栽培醸造それからシステム開発とか
研究というものを現場に入れてくるくる回してるんですが
今はですね大学の中では a 幕にプロを使って生産者のですねその
用ブドウの品質を上げるために必要な
センシング技術の開発というのをやっています細かい話は今日はしませんけれども
いろんなそのセンサー開発をやる中でですね一つ私が農家や消費者と一緒に幸せな社会
ハッピーの社会を築くために気をつけていることというか気をつけていることがあり
ましてそれは私は哲学なんですけれども
あのー農家が考えることをやめてしまうようなシステム開発は絶対にしたくないという
ことを胸に秘めています
こう写真を撮ったときこの農家さんは天を突くように指を高々と上げながらなぜこの枝
を
ここに残したのかというのを私に説明してくれました
つまりこの農家さんはこの枝を残さないといけない意味を考えられる人だからです
だからこんなにしっかりと指をさせるんですねでこの人が観光いう農家さんたちが今
自分たちがやっている一つ一つの作業の意味をですね
考えることをやめてしまうようなシステムをつくってしまってそれが僕はやりすぎだと
思っています
ぽい各あのキープ選挙考え続けられるためそしてもっとより深いことを農家さんたちが
考えていけるようなそういうシステム開発をしたいと思って日々研究開発に取り組んで
います
私あの大学での研究以外にもですねまあセンサー会社とかいろんなその
ベンチャーをを手掛けてたりもするんですけれども
まあこれ半額半民て勝手に言っているんですが半額半民をしているのには理由があり
ます
研究者が一番にがちなところなんですがやはり自分がその開発した
もしくはその研究成果をですね
やはりまず一度世に問うということをやるべきだと思っています
一度世に問いといてですねそれが必要だと言ってもらえたら闇社会実装して
1技術として社会に定着するところまで責任を持たなくちゃいけないというのが私の
考えで
まあこの勢いでですねまだしばらくはやっていきたいなと思って
今日のテーマは replace オーブアイディアということでどこまでそのテーマ
に添えてそれ誰かわかりませんけれども
アイディアというものはただその形にするだけとかでせ持っているだけでは非常に
もったいないもので僕はそのアイディアというところにはですね情熱が乗っかって
初めて広がっていくものだと思うんですよ
情熱が乗っかって広がったアイディアというのは必ず同時にですね人を幸せにするその
ハッピーな波て残せると思っ
こういうそのハッピーな波をですねもともと少しでも微々たるうち彼しか私は
持ち合わせていませんがまあ少なくともこのワインづくりというものを通して少しも
広げていけたらなと
ありがとうございました